it has been a while since the last book
video came out so I thought I would do
this and talk about the books I've been
reading as you can see I've been reading
a fair bit over the past couple of
months for those of you who are new by
the way to this kind of series of book
stuff on this channel this is where I
talk about why I've been reading
normally over the past couple of months
to be fair hasn't been that regular I
review the books that I've been reading
talk about what I liked what I didn't
like and then give a recommendation or a
lack of recommendation
there's be new to the channel hi my name
is Simon I just finished the PhD in
atmospheric physics and I'm now a
full-time science communicator I along
with those geeky things happen to like
books surprise surprise and the first
book I want to talk about is never split
the difference by Chris Voss so Chris
Foss was a negotiator in the FBI
he was the person who'd be on the phone
to the kidnappers the terrorists the
whatever the bank robbers and would be
the person talking them down negotiating
with them and basically wrote a book
collecting the I think there's ten
lessons in here it might be eight or
something like that ten I was right he
found most useful and is a very easy to
read book actually um a lot of these
what I think of as like self-help books
this isn't a self-help book but they can
be like fluff it's like just get to the
point already this wasn't like that it's
actually relatively slim but it contains
genuinely very useful information my PhD
vibe is coming up and I'm gonna be
rereading this to pick up um or refresh
a few tips on how to do even though
that's it's kind of a negotiation I
suppose and the vibra I'm defending my
research but I have to convince somebody
that I am you know worth giving a PhD to
and there are some very very useful
things in this for example the process
of saying no and building to the point
where you say yes and also convincing
somebody on the other side of the table
to agree to to something not immediately
but by building to that point making it
more likely that they are actually going
to see through the plans that you have
mutually made like genuinely very very
useful things so I definitely recommend
this to anyone who is interested in
basically getting more out of
interpersonal kind of negotiations and
that doesn't have to be a formal
negotiation it could be an interview or
it could be
like haggling like there's a business
story about somebody bringing the price
of a car down and this I think it's
actually possum self they useful life
lessons to learn um I honestly would
recommend this to pretty much anybody
well though I will say the thing that
made me shy back and giving it like a
complete five-star glowing review was
that there isn't it's not exactly life
changing like the book is what it is
useful lessons but kind of nothing more
than that and I like the fact that it's
sort of unassuming in that sense like it
doesn't have tensions that it's somehow
this is you know this book is gonna
change your life
it doesn't try and do that but at the
same time I felt like there was a kind
of spark missing from it so very very
good but not fantastic this stands in
contrast to the next book the
Underground Railroad by Colson whitehead
so I bought this book in Bristol Airport
when I was gonna be going on a quick
holiday like a couple of days away to
Croatia and so I devoured this book over
the course of like four days or
something like that and it completely
dreamy in it completely sucked me into
the world and really shook me up
actually I realized that a lot of the
books that I talk about here and also on
my Goodreads which I'll link down there
which has like full reviews of
everything I'm talking about I realized
that a lot of the stuff I talked about
is nonfiction because I don't know maybe
it's just the way I am but this was a
conscious effort to read more fiction
and I picked it up basically because it
won the Pulitzer Prize and Barack Obama
said it was terrific and would you know
what he was right because not only is
this a fantastic story it's a story
about basically to runaway slaves from a
plantation in the south of America
cheering well the breeze of a warrior it
also taught me an awful lot about I
don't wanna say subtleties but sort of
certainly here in the UK lesser-known
aspects of slavery like the things that
they did not gonna spoil anything but
the things that North Carolina I think
it was to do with the hospitals and also
what you could think of is like the
resistance to slavery the titular
Underground Railroad which for those of
you who don't know and I didn't know
this was the series of people across
America who would try and convey escaped
slaves to the north and to safety
whereas if they stayed in the south they
could be hunted down and one of the
antagonists in the book is effectively a
bounty hunter for slaves he would
caPSURE slaves bring them back to their
old masters in fact scattered throughout
the book there are adverts that were
placed here's one real adverts which
were placed to base the advertised
saying look I've lost this slave the
girl of this age than these
distinguishing things and then people
would read those efforts and go and
catch these people and bring them back
light of a property well because I
suppose to the people the slave owners
that's what they were so for the story
for the mixing of fiction and history
and the things that I learned from it
that alone highly highly recommended
that I mean I gave this book five stars
on Goodreads I thought it was fantastic
but more than I also made me realise
that some pretty much everything else
I've read in my life has been by a white
guy and it's normally a guy yes I have
read some some books by women but it's
almost comic how narrow my reading has
been so this has really spurred me to
seek out other books written by authors
of color and you know voices that I very
dissimilar to my everyday existence so I
have all my Goodreads actually I put in
a whole bunch of books what you're gonna
try and fulfill that so I'm very keen to
read more like this so it's a very good
book and it's kind of transformative so
very solid recommendation next another
fantastic book Isaac Newton by James go
like this was an impulse buy um I have
as you'll see at the end of this video
so many books that I need to read but
when I saw this in what's the cambridge
version the Blackwell's heifers in
cambridge i had to buy it i bought like
three books my girlfriend left me alone
and unattended like five minutes and i
came back and i bought like three or
four books but I had to get this I just
had to because I have yet to read a good
sort of authoritative biography of Isaac
Newton I've read a few things as a kid
so I know a fair bit about his life I
did still learn things from this what I
will definitely say is that this is
eight fantastically researched and
fantastically written biography
it's actually quite small for a man of
Newton stature who was so unbelievably
influential and you know I'm saying that
as a physicist
that he had influence on other areas
like the Royal Mint and how currency is
used in the UK it's less than 200 pages
and it at it's one of these books where
each sentence has been very very
carefully worded to get the maximum
meaning out of the sentence and I'm
definitely needing me read more gleich
because this good yeah this is like my
paradigm now for how well you can write
the prose in a biography so as you might
expect for a biography
it starts at its childhood and it works
for words it doesn't tend to jump around
much and I will say that from a
scientific perspective it mostly talks
about his theory of gravity which is
phenomenal and his prin and if I might
try to pronounce it Principia or pink
appear the bigger book that he wrote
about physics it focuses on those and so
his laws of motion as well but it
doesn't provide a huge amount of detail
apart from in gravity which you know I
just finished a PhD in atmospheric
physics I might be alone and wanting a
little bit more scientific detail but
yeah I could have done with a little bit
more detail on that stuff of course I
don't need to tell you the Newton was a
genius and a brilliant physicist you
know if a probably the greatest
physicist of all time and the book just
get that across one of the chapters is
literally called is he like other men
the answer to it is basically no but the
interesting thing that it gets across is
that he was from also a fundamentally
strange quite bitter cold cruel man and
the other thing is he is very petulant
which I didn't know actually deploy I
read this that basically when things
didn't go his way he was like ah I'm
just gonna cut the rest of the world I'm
not gonna write trying to me don't reply
to him I'm just gonna shut myself away
in Cambridge and credit to the book and
credit took like as I've said for
writing it so well because it's an
engaging read it's it's quite heavy
material really you know like the
development of the first field theory
and the foundations of modern physics
and you know overthrowing the way in
which the we thought about the universe
before this really the cement them as
being so significant the thing I will
say against this book is that it suffers
from a lack of overall arc like an
overall I it's a biography it's not
fiction I know but it suffers from a
lack of overall story and I think
compares poorly with the strangest man
which is about paul dirac what another
amazing physicist by Graham farmer
though which has we inherently because
of who drought was it has much more of
an arc to it and I highly recommend that
if you don't read that and that's the
best biography I've ever read
and this suffered from that possibly I'm
just appalled because that is such a
fantastic book but this could have done
with more of a yeah more of an overall
structure to it but still again another
recommendation then penultimately I'm
going to talk very quickly about two
very geeky books so these are flight the
Einstein by James swallow and fulgrim by
Graeme McNeil I'm a massive fan of all
hammer 40,000 and I have read countless
Warhammer 40k books these are in the
Horus heresy series which is an ongoing
series of like 40 books now or something
crazy
these are towards the start I'm making
my way through them after a long hiatus
and I will briefly review these as they
are fun if you know the law but they are
also interesting to read as somebody who
was interested in writing and
interesting in reviewing books because
they're not well written in fact that
supremely overran I enjoyed them but I
wouldn't recommend them to anyone who's
like who's not a die-hard for UK fan and
then finally we come to the most
talked-about book in this video which is
Turtles all the way down by John Green
now I actually don't have a copy with me
because I lent it to my girlfriend
because I basically pressed it on her
and was like you need to read this which
funnily enough was when I said to a lot
of people about The Fault in Our Stars
Green's previous book but my short
review of turtles as I'm gonna refer to
it because it's quite early title is
that it's fantastic I think it's an
important book the comparison I make on
my Goodreads review of it is comparing
it to the Fault in Our Stars which
obviously went on to huge commercial
success you know it was a worldwide
bestseller it was turned into a film you
know it was this huge phenomenon I am
gonna guess that this book will not
cause such a phenomenon but I think it
is much more mature and I think it is a
better book Tippi
The Fault in Our Stars dealt with
teenagers with cancer
falling in love going to apps that I
mean it was like a fairy tale story and
in that sense comparing it to Turtles to
me is like comparing Pride and Prejudice
by Jane Austen with persuasion also by
Austen one it's very very famous and
it's come out see in fairy tale which is
definitely what tiffy osis was like and
persuasion is much more realistic it was
written later in her career and she had
a much more moderate realistic view
about romance I guess and that is my
impression of turtles it is written by
an author who is a bit older who is more
mature in their craft and is more
confident in what they are saying and
much as I wish that the book is gonna go
on and be just as successful I can't
help but feel like it won't because
maybe people aren't ready for that
realism especially be marketed as a
young adult novel crime if I'm wrong
here
I know this is a generalization but I
feel like the young adults don't
necessarily want something that is
realistic or bleak they want something
perhaps that's more idealistic
but coming in as an adult reader I
enjoyed it more and I was hit quite hard
emotionally by bits of the book like The
Fault in Our Stars it deals with a very
sick young woman who is the protagonist
and her close friends and her romantic
life I'm not gonna say anything more
spoilery than that so you could argue
that there are parallels between the two
books and when I started reading it I
got into the story and I thought oh here
we go
it's exactly like all those other books
you know it's like tiffy oh there's the
young overly intellectual girl who's
gonna be falling in love or it's going
to be like his previous novels where
there's this idealized person they're
gonna fall for them but he presumably
completely consciously flips that on its
head and instead takes that framework in
two complete different directions kind
of says well you know what forget about
that mystery adventure story like that
it's actually delve into these
characters and it's let's talk about
what is wrong here because while cancer
was the sickness of
before that stars anxiety and I suppose
you could say more broadly mental health
is the sickness in Turtles all the way
down as somebody who has suffered from
mental health problems in the past I
won't again I won't give any spoilers to
this but as the book kind of swept
towards the climax of the story it
things get bad basically and I thought
oh wow okay perhaps you could have gone
a little bit further then it's great
that the ideas are on the stage and
being seen and talked about but okay I
feel like it's been shoved under the rug
not at all because at the very end
in the very last chapter it's it's
almost like the book takes on a
completely new life and like it's
speaking directly to you it doesn't but
it's as if he is speaking directly to
you about these issues and a maps out a
future I was yeah okay I can't say
anything more than that maps out a
future which I don't know just suddenly
speak spoke to me certainly on a very
very very deep level one I don't know if
that's because I'm I've had experiences
and I don't have in the past or because
I'm human but it was profoundly
affecting the end and I put it down I
remember reading it in bed finished it
and I just sat there thinking about it
for a long long time and just thinking
to myself after a while yeah this this
feels like an important book I know that
his other books are talked on in some
schools and abandoned some other schools
but I really hope that this gets widely
read by young people because it's an
important discussion about mental health
if I were to offer any criticism I would
say that it shares previous faults with
his with his other books in that his
protagonists young people you know
they're teenagers in school and they
have incredibly intellectual thoughts
and conversations and you in reading it
I can basically hear John Green's voice
I can I can from his YouTube work
I can hear that bad these are his
thoughts and you just can't help but
think this is not how this is not spoken
with the eloquence of a 16 year old or a
15 year old this is spoken with the
eloquence of a 30 year old or a 40 year
old who is thought about these issues
for a long
john green's teenagers are always very
very smart and intellectual and i think
a lot of people's problems with it is
that they are too smart and too eloquent
and not reread presentative of teenagers
perhaps teenagers think they are that
smart but don't think in reality any any
teenager I've met has been quite as
bright as any of the people in John
Green's books so that is that I think
you could say as criticism you could
also argue that the lack of kind of like
adventure frame you're hanging on is a
criticism but I didn't mind those I
thought it was a wonderful book
definitely recommend it so this video is
already going on for way too long so I'm
just gonna quickly round off with what
I'm currently reading which is memes in
digital culture by Italy more Schiffman
which is a quite hardcore theoretical
discussion of memes in society and not
just comparing them to sort of Dawkins
idea of memes but actually really quite
detailed sociological stuff and the
Prince by Machiavelli a book that I've
been meaning to read for a very long
time because I know it's all about
basically sort of how to gain power and
hold on to it and I feel like that's
something I know a little about and it
might be useful maybe to learn about so
far it's about half way through it's
quite dense and I definitely if there's
definitely a few quotations that send
into my mind I was like oh that's good
but I haven't become a prince yet so I
don't know mixed review and then
following up from the Prince I actually
have a whole bunch of these penguin did
a cool series of big thoughts you know
in like I guess you could call them
pamphlets so like common sense by Thomas
Paine so I'm gonna make my way through
these one by one
I haven't actually started the Nietzsche
why I am so wise don't like Nietzsche
I don't think and then between those I'm
also going to be reading Artemis by Andy
weir who I met in fact this copy was
signed for me a couple of days ago Andy
really nice guy so that's gonna be like
my pulpy filler between the two because
I love the Martian and based on the talk
he gave when I got it signed
this is gonna be this is gonna be fun
and then finally I have a whole bunch of
other books that I still need to read
which I've been saying I'm gonna read
for quite some time like history the
bottom 12 maps 15 million degrees the
water book I think two new ones which I
haven't mentioned are flat land my very
very battered copy of flatland and
so a romance of many dimensions and
Eureka which is about the birth of one
science and how the Greeks basically
kind of laid the foundations what we
think of as science nowadays this was a
Christmas present from the girlfriends
family so this is this is gonna be
actually three looks it looks like a
quick read but very interesting like I
mentioned earlier if you want any more
detail on my reviews of these books or
what else I've got on my shelf to read
there's a link to my Goodreads down
there in the description and also in the
description are Amazon links to the
books that I've been talking about in
this video I would suggest that you try
and support your local book shops where
possible because I love a good book shop
but I realized that's not possible for
everyone so yeah if you want to get one
those books on Amazon links down there
thank you for watching this video
I realize it's been quite a long one but
if you have any thoughts on the books
that I've been talking about this video
please do leave them in the comments
below in particular if you have any
thoughts about tackles all the way down
I'd be interested to hear them because
based on Goodreads opinions need to be
somewhat split and then if you have any
further recommendations not that I don't
have a whole pile of books and my feet
already if you have any recommendations
for me then please do put those in the
comments as well give the video a like
if you enjoyed it and if you're not
already please subscribe to the channel
for more book videos in the future
thanks for watching I'll see you next
time
[Music]